I'm hoping what I said could make you
change your mind no it doesn't really
matter when my hands are tied
I'm trying to work what's going on guys
my name is Everett homage and welcome
back to the channel today we're going to
be talking about the brand new iphone XS
and Y in my personal opinion you
shouldn't be rushing to the Apple store
and throwing $1,700 a Nutella
just yet now I've been an Android user
pretty much my whole life and I'm a
little bit biased however I'm only gonna
be focusing on the XS here and the X
itself and why these two comparisons are
so similar that you don't really need to
be going and throwing the extra money
away for no reason just yet now I'm not
just gonna say negative things about the
iPhone here when you pick up the phone
you can tell that it's absolutely
premium quality the build itself is
solid the glass in the front and back
really gives it that unique feel and
something that kind of reminds me back
of the old iPhone for five days
however the glass back is an absolute
fingerprint magnet every time you touch
it a new fingerprints there and a new
smudges there I found its best to
straight away pop its skin on it or pop
some sort of cover on top to make sure
you protect it as much as possible being
the last obviously does scratch and
scrape very easily and if you ever plan
on reselling an iPhone you know that the
most valuable when they're in premium
condition however again the iPhone X has
the absolute same build quality the same
glass back in front and if you're
comparing the iPhone X to the iPhone XS
they're identical for hardware builds
something I found a little bit strange
and this is more an Apple thing that an
iPhone X or an iPhone xx thing is the
fact that when you compare the Space
Gray Apple MacBook Pro and the Space
Gray iPhone X s they're completely
different colors you think buying the
same color from the same brand you kind
of end up with two very similar items
however it's completely different here
the Space Gray MacBook is almost a very
silvery color whilst space coat I phone
is almost closer to the black side of
things so if we take a look at the spec
sheets between the two the XS and the X
actually aren't too different from an
actual physical your body point of view
that almost identical there's only a
couple minor differences between the XS
and
X itself unless you're going out and
purchasing the gold version of the XS
nobody in their right mind is going to
be able to tell that you're holding an
excess in your hand versus just an X
itself so if we take a look at the
internal specs this is where we find
something a little bit different the XS
has an 800 binding chip whereas the X
only has the ALM and chip Apple has said
that the 812 chip is significantly more
powerful and can do a lot of things
better than there then a 11 chip can
it's improving so far but it's
performing in about 15 to 30 percent
better than the a 11 however with the
new iOS 12 update on the X the
differences between two aren't that vast
both come in a 64 and a 256 gigabyte
option for storage
however the XS does have a 512 gigabyte
option as well over the X which it does
not but when you actually consider the
price of the 512 model it's well and
above almost any phone in the market
surpassing 2,000 dollars Australian when
you look at the rear cameras of the two
you're going to notice that they're
actually identical from a hardware point
of view the only difference here is the
XS has a software upgrade which allows
you to manipulate the artificial Boker
in the background anywhere from ff1
point 4 to f-16 now all the reviews that
I've seen online for the XS and the X
itself incredibly long some of them
upwards of 20 30 minutes I didn't want
to make that in this video I wanted to
make this video short sharp and sweet
and really consolidate my points as
quickly as possible the faculty matter
is that the XS doesn't have that much of
an upgrade or leg up on the X to justify
the price difference do you have the
ability to go out buy a brand new iPhone
X or a secondhand iPhone X near new
condition for significantly cheaper
price than $1,700 for the XS I would
personally recommend going for that
option hands-down however if you have
the liberty of waiting a little bit
longer and unable to wait for the new
iPhone 11 or iPhone 12 whatever they
decide to call it then chances are that
this iPhone is going to come with a lot
more out of benefits and a completely
new reimagined look so far the world's
talking and the rumors are all out and
about and we're looking at brand new
things like increase battery life even
more powerful processing chips under the
glass fingerprint recognition and better
face ID now these changes in my
opinion will justify the difference in
price and the difference in the models
the fingerprint sensor underneath the
glass is actually one of the key things
that I look forward to in most new
flagship smartphones because the
fingerprint scanner always tends to work
a lot quicker and a lot better than any
face 1t and that's it for me today guys
if you like this video make sure you
smash that subscribe button
20:19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday